[Música]
representantes del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y también representantes de la
oposición se reunieron nuevamente en
Ciudad de México en un renovado diálogo
que tiene varios puntos como objetivos
siendo el principal de ellos Establecer
un marco para unas elecciones libres en
el 2024 en donde van a elegir el nuevo
presidente de Venezuela en los primeros
días de estas conversaciones pues ya han
llegado a varios acuerdos bastante
representativos los diálogos fueron
suspendidos en octubre del 2021 por eso
estamos hablando de un renovado diálogo
entre las partes entre los puntos que
hay en la agenda pues está a buscar una
manera para recuperar esos recursos del
Estado venezolano que están en el
exterior ambas partes también buscan
aprovechar esa crisis energética que hay
a nivel mundial para que Venezuela
recupere una posición en el mercado una
maniobra que le traería muchísimos
recursos económicos y con esto pues
podrían levantar justamente el aparato
productor del país Poco después de
alcanzado un acuerdo en torno a estos
puntos el departamento del tesoro de
Estados Unidos justamente autorizó a la
petrolera Chevron a retomar sus
operaciones en Venezuela algo muy
significativo para las relaciones
internacionales de ese país suramericano
justamente hay mucha expectativa a nivel
regional y por qué no decirlo a nivel
internacional sobre este nuevo intento
de diálogo en Venezuela desde la
oposición para ver primera para ver una
primera cara de la moneda dicen que
buscan garantías para esas elecciones
libres escuchemos con mucha esperanza y
mucha fuerza
para ir ahora a la agenda que
corresponde a la producción de las
condiciones que puedan
realizarse o convenirse mejor dicho y
que puedan garantizar la elecciones
libres a los venezolanos
que puedan garantizarle condiciones en
las cuales la alternabilidad en el poder
pueda materializarse con el respeto al
voto
Y también
vamos a buscar en toda esta negociación
el respeto a los derechos políticos el
respeto a los Derechos Humanos ahora
veamos La otra cara de la moneda desde
el lado oficialista reiteran su
necesidad de recuperar esos recursos en
el exterior para que sirva para reformar
ciertos puntos importantes del sistema
de salud venezolano y también Para
apoyar a esos cientos de damnificados
por las inundaciones en diferentes
estados del país como hay más de 20.000
millones de
represados bloqueados injustamente
apropiados por el sistema financiero por
bancos extranjeros por sanciones
groseras que violentan el orden
internacional nosotros queremos anunciar
que por vía de este acuerdo estamos
Rescatando más de 3000 millones de
dólares que van directamente al
financiamiento de educación de salud de
electricidad a la atención directa de
las víctimas de las tragedias por las
lluvias torrenciales que ha sufrido
Venezuela
desde Miraflores Nicolás Maduro celebró
la firma de este primer acuerdo parcial
lo calificó como un nuevo capítulo para
Venezuela
la firma del segundo acuerdo parcial
entre el gobierno bolivariano que
preside y la plataforma unitaria de una
de las oposiciones abre paso a un nuevo
capítulo para Venezuela en función de
seguir avanzando hacia la paz y el
bienestar que todas y todos los
venezolanos anhelamos y ya se ven
algunas de las repercusiones porque este
episodio coincide con un resurgimiento
de Venezuela a escala internacional en
un escenario mundial en el que Venezuela
tiene mucho para ofrecer sobre todo en
la actual crisis energética esto ha
llevado a un incipiente de acercamiento
entre Caracas y Washington y ahí que el
tesoro de Estados Unidos haya permitido
que la empresa Chevron retomara sus
operaciones en Venezuela según la
empresa Esto va muy en sintonía con esa
política de larga Data de Estados Unidos
de aliviar las sanciones específicas en
algunos países veamos esta acción
refleja la política de larga Data de
Estados Unidos de proporcionar un alivio
de sanciones específico basado en pasos
concretos que alivian el sufrimiento del
pueblo venezolano y apoyan la
restauración de la democracia con este
panorama ya más claro aquí es donde
entonces vienen las preguntas qué otros
temas están sobre esta mesa de diálogo
cómo será ese marco de esas garantías
para las elecciones libres en Venezuela
está el gobierno de maduro solamente es
significando ante la comunidad
internacional aprovechando esa imagen
que tiene ahora para recuperar activos
en el exterior y seguir financiándose a
través de ellos que tanto está Estados
Unidos dispuesto a ceder en cuanto a las
sanciones solo por la necesidad de
adquirir petróleo venezolano Estos y
otros muchos temas Pues los vamos a
analizar en el debate de France 24 para
conversar sobre este tema importante
para la región de América Latina hemos
invitado a Williams Dávila él es
diputado opositor por el partido Acción
democrática y también está con nosotros
Víctor Hugo Juárez él es
internacionalista y profesor del
programa de comercio internacional de la
universidad ssi les recuerdo que ustedes
también nuestros televidentes hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales ya saben estamos en
Twitter en Facebook También estamos en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate guión bajo
f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
junto no olviden también que todos los
contenidos del programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn agradecemos a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de estas diferentes plataformas
de podcast de France 24
le doy la bienvenida entonces a mi
primer invitado a Williams y comienzo
preguntándole a Williams Gracias por
estar con nosotros y pues mi primera
pregunta es y es tal vez una uno de los
cuestionamientos que se hace la
comunidad internacional se puede confiar
en esta mesa de diálogo en esta
participación del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y la oposición nuevamente allí en
México cuál es su punto de vista
bueno en primer lugar Muchas gracias
Santiago por por este debate ya France
24 obviamente por la facilitación del
mismo y al INE y a todos los que
trabajan en este equipo Bueno yo creo
que por la fuerza misma de las
circunstancias el
régimen que es el que primero le dio una
patada a la mesa el año pasado al
acuerdo o a la negociación en México
porque querían privilegiar Alexa
sabe perfectamente bien que si en este
momento no cumplen con ese acuerdo
las sanciones no las van a levantar no
van a conseguir recursos tan fácilmente
de manera tal de que
maduro sabe perfectamente bien Que si
quiere ganar credibilidad en la
comunidad internacional y lo que más
importante lo que él acaba de decir que
este es un camino hacia la paz tener una
paz de verdad una paz social una paz
institu en el país se tienen que honrar
estos compromisos internacionales que
comenzó con esta parte social yo creo
que eso es importante señalarlo porque
hoy día Venezuela
está sumergida en una grave crisis no
solamente humanitaria sino que a
consecuencia de los desastres naturales
eso acarrea más pobreza porque ese es el
efecto posterior del desastre de la
lluvia sin carreteras sin cosechas sin
producción Entonces en este momento hay
un hay una hay una una base allí que
obliga necesariamente que cumplan Los
acuerdos hay escepticismo no para
terminar mi respuesta y escepticismo
porque el primer acuerdo firmado el año
pasado no lo cumplió maduro por ejemplo
el tema del ese equipo que podemos
hablar de eso después ahí no cumplió no
convocó al país nacional
hay mucha expectativa ya lo decía yo en
la introducción del programa Williams
hay mucha expectativa no solamente en la
región sino también a nivel
internacional en torno a esta mesa de
diálogo que ya comienza a arrojar
algunos resultados paso ahora a darle la
bienvenida a Víctor Hugo nuestro
siguiente invitado también Punto de
partida pregunta en común para conocer
posiciones de los invitados Víctor Hugo
Gracias por estar con nosotros los
saludo en la ciudad de Bogotá y se puede
confiar en esta mesa de diálogo se puede
confiar en en esta posición que tiene el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición para esta mesa de diálogo Cuál
es su análisis
bueno ante todo un cordial saludo Muchas
gracias por el espacio de diálogo
intercambio de opiniones a nivel de los
asuntos internacionales un saludo al
diputado William y a esta cadena de
análisis internacional creo que
fundamentalmente el el el diálogo
siempre es una salida es una opción
viable para cualquier coyuntura que se
pueda presentar creo que ante todo el
mejor escenario para dirimir las
diferencias entre las distintas
sociedades es el diálogo la concertación
En ese sentido eso va pegado a los
principios básicos de la carta de
Naciones Unidas y todo lo que tiene que
ver con los organismos multilaterales en
materia respeto de Derechos Humanos Pero
principalmente ya cuando entramos al
análisis desde el punto de vista de ir
mirando a profundidad los factores que
están asociados a este nuevo proceso
equivocado entre el gobierno y la
oposición creo que es otro escenario
internacional distinto en ese sentido
Estados Unidos la administración vaiden
está buscando suplir el mercado
petrolero que deja a la deriva producto
de la situación en Ucrania en este
sentido por eso está iniciando desde
hace algunos meses ese proceso de
intercambio con la administración o con
el régimen de Nicolás maduro pero
también Creo que del lado de la
oposición Busca refrescar ante una
imagen muy debilitada a nivel
internacional sobre todo la vinculación
del líder opositores en hechos de
corrupción con el manejo de los recursos
específicamente en el tema de la ayuda
humanitaria y todo lo que el movimiento
y el fenómeno que originó
la figura del gobierno interino que
afectó tanto a la oposición y que
ahorita tanto gobierno como posición
tiene una Ema imagen muy debilitada de
Cara a las elecciones presidenciales A
ver vamos a ir por partes y continuó con
Víctor Hugo para hacer la ronda la
inversa quiero que veamos por por partes
los que están allí sentados reunidos
dialogando Víctor Hugo Qué cartas tiene
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro para
jugarse en esta mesa de diálogo qué
tanto tiene para perder Y qué cartas
tiene para ofrecer
la principal carta que tiene el gobierno
de maduro es la reserva de petróleo Pero
hay un gran problema que no tiene la
capacidad de refinación En ese sentido
le entregaría todo ese proceso a las
grandes transnacionales en el caso
específicamente de los Estados Unidos
para buscar
generar ese proceso de
refinación o ese proceso de elaboración
de los derivados producto de la
actividad energética creo que
fundamentalmente la preocupación del
gobierno es el tema de las sanciones
pero para ello tiene que dar un paso
importante sobre todo en materia de
respeto de los Derechos Humanos ahí está
la propuesta de Colombia incorporarlo a
lo que tiene que ver el la
reincorporación de Venezuela al sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos y
específicamente también es lograr esa
legitimidad no del gobierno sino del
proceso electoral creo que es un punto
neurálgico el acompañamiento que se
genere por parte de la administración
vaide y por parte de la Unión Europea y
pasó a preguntarle ahora a Williams La
otra cara de la moneda Cuáles son las
cartas a jugar de la oposición por
primera vez vamos a ver una oposición de
Venezuela unida unificada aliada para
tener un frente común para esta mesa de
negociación Cuál es su análisis
Sí yo creo Santiago que la gran mayoría
de la gente quiere pues de acuerdo se
cumpla porque se
vislumbraría en el Horizonte una salida
democrática para que tengamos elecciones
presidenciales libres con condiciones
subjetivas electorales y y además
presencia internacional yo lo que sé la
agenda fundamental el objetivo no es
solamente un acuerdo el objetivo es ir
hacia unas elecciones libres que
implique el llegar a ese objetivo
liberación de presos políticos ver el
problema de la de la judicialización de
los partidos políticos el hecho mismo de
que existen más de 240 personas
presos de conciencia de los cuales 10
son mujeres tenemos
120 personas de la sociedad civil presos
de conciencia O sea no es cualquier cosa
que se haya llegado a ese nivel en un
país en donde no tiene un conflicto
armado como lo tuvo Colombia y sin
embargo los resultados son como que si
hubiéramos vivido una guerra siete
millones cien mil venezolanos por fuera
Entonces es una agenda política
humana como lo acaba de decir el
profesor Víctor
efectivamente de derechos humanos y esto
se de Derechos Humanos
eso no es un no es un regalo no es una
concesión de nadie ese es un derecho que
nosotros tenemos que exigirlo en la
calle porque aquí en Venezuela se han
violado de manera sistemática eso
derecho humano entonces aquí una agenda
muy completa y ahí donde viene el punto
Hasta qué Hasta qué nivel maduro está
dispuesto a entrar a esa discusión con
resultados concretos Porque si bien es
cierto hay una mesa de negociación en
México se llega ahí por algo se llega
porque hay una crisis se llega porque
aquí se acabó la industria petrolera si
nosotros Mira tuviéramos con la misma
producción de cuando llegó Chávez al
poder tres millones y tanto de barriles
de petróleo por 50 dólares el barril No
tendríamos necesidad de estar este
liberando recursos por fuera y se llegó
a esa a esa congelación de activo
precisamente para preservarlo para
evitar que esos recursos fueran
utilizados de manera corrupta por Maduro
Y eso más bien ha sido un logro del
gobierno interino y de la asamblea
nacional que ha logrado preservar esos
activos entonces hay una situación Pues
que la agenda no está es muy concreta y
tienen que ver elecciones libres Pero
tiene que ver garantías de respeto de
los Derechos Humanos porque es un deber
del Estado garantizar proteger y
promover los Derechos Humanos Williams
continuó con usted garantías es la
palabra
destacada de esta intervención suya pero
como garantizar esas elecciones libres
en un país donde se critica mucho la
independencia de los poderes donde se
critica justamente que el poder
electoral
no goza de las garantías y no gozar la
libertad que
quiere para este tipo de procesos por lo
menos es muy criticado por la comunidad
internacional
Cuáles van a ser las bases para esas
garantías qué es lo que pide la
oposición para poder decir Estamos de
acuerdo con lo que se está marcando aquí
en en el marco de la negociación para
poder realizar esos comicios en plena
Libertad en el 2024
Bueno mira Santiago hay que estar hay
que estar Claro que esta es una lucha
que se está dando dentro de un régimen
autocrático contra el régimen
autocrático no estamos en una democracia
plena
hay partidos intervenidos hay presos
políticos nosotros necesitamos que haya
libertad de expresión aquí hay la prensa
escrita no existe los medios televisivos
oficiales de señal abierta se les
complica mucho a veces tener programas
de opinión crítica o sea aquí tiene que
ver ese tipo de de compromiso libertad
de expresión hay que tratar el tema de
la judicialización de los partidos
políticos hay que tratar el tema de la
inhabilitación de dirigentes que pueden
ser candidatos que están inhabilitados O
sea tenemos un problema serio que para
llegar a esas condiciones de elecciones
libres requiere una presión social y una
presión internacional para que el
régimen entienda que se acabó Ya la
etapa de la dictadura que tiene que
abrirse y darse cuenta que no solamente
el problema económico sino que también
tenemos problemas políticos y un
problema humano
Víctor Hugo Cuál es su opinión sobre
estas garantías que piden para las
elecciones libres Cómo empezar a
construirlas Y cómo justamente dar las
bases para que ambas partes se sientan
cómodas para realizar ese proceso
electoral yo creo que ahí juego un papel
fundamental la comunidad internacional
es decir el proceso de acompañamiento
que que van a hacer los países garantes
también los organismos multilaterales ya
sea a nivel de Naciones Unidas a nivel
de la Organización de Estados Americanos
va a plantear un escenario
propicio para definir una hoja de ruta
que permita llegar a puntos concretos Lo
que pasa que yo considero ahí difiere un
poco del diputado creo que no debemos
tener una visión solamente concentrada
en el evento electoral creo que
evidentemente
pueden existir puntos estructurales
puntos en materia de
lo que tiene que ver con la
reconciliación como sociedad como
venezolanos y que evidentemente ambas
partes
tengan las garantías políticas plenas
que establece claramente la Constitución
y los principales instrumentos en
materia internacional y también quisiera
tener un punto o aportar acá el debate
el tema del autocrítica que tiene que
tener el liderazgo opositor yo creo que
de parte también de que se le diga la
verdad qué ocurrió a nivel de los
venezolanos que estamos en el exterior
pero también de la ciudadanía que se
encuentra actualmente en Venezuela que
se dé una auditoría de todo ese proceso
y esa cantidad de recursos que se
recaudaron durante la figura del
gobierno interino entonces creo que así
como el gobierno debe reflexionar
también el liderazgo opositor debe
reflexionar porque que también se
pudiera interpretar desde el punto de
vista de lo que siempre ha ocurrido que
el gobierno utiliza el diálogo como un
mecanismo de obtener algún avance de
materiales y tinidad internacional y
como un mecanismo de oxígeno que cuando
considera que la mesa ya no tiene ningún
sentido simplemente separa y detiene el
diálogo entonces creo que aquí debería
haber un proceso auto reflexivo por
parte tanto de la oposición como del
gobierno donde evidentemente la
prioridad debe tener o debe ser los
elementos estructurales que están
asociados al tema macroeconómico al
manejo de lo que tiene que ver los
intereses políticos y que realmente la
ciudadanía se siente identificado con
ese proceso de diálogo Víctor continuó
con ustedes en ese orden de ideas que
tanto está el gobierno de maduro
dispuesto a reconocer la presencia de
los presos políticos esa presión que se
ha ejercido sobre los medios de
comunicación hemos visto en las últimas
semanas las denuncias precisamente por
el cierre de varias emisoras regionales
en diferentes estados de Venezuela la
presión que han recibido los partidos
políticos y también
esa incapacidad digámoslo así del
gobierno de maduro a reconocer a la
oposición no como un enemigo sino como
una oposición política que tiene una
visión distinta del país
están dispuestos a eso están dispuestos
a reconocer porque eso le traería muchas
condenas a nivel internacional
así no estén dispuestos a reconocer creo
que están o el escenario internacional
los obliga a desarrollar una estrategia
distinta porque no es el mismo gobierno
de hace algunos años evidentemente de
hecho se plantea la posibilidad de que
ellos busquen adelantar hacer unas
elecciones Express sorpresiva tomando en
cuenta de la desorganización y las
fracturas internas que tiene la
oposición no obstante creo que el
gobierno
debe tener la claridad
realmente que esta o que pudiera estar
dispuesto a acceder sobre todo por el
tema de la reincorporación de Venezuela
en muchos mecanismos de cooperación
internacional en materia económica
entonces principalmente el gobierno así
le genere algún tipo de ruido el tema de
derecho humano creo que está en la
obligación de sentarse racionalmente
porque también es importante si el
gobierno pierde las elecciones ellos
pasarían a ser oposición y necesitan
garantizar necesitan garantizar que
puedan tener las los parámetros o el
escenario idóneo a seguir ejerciendo la
política Yo creo que el gobierno
necesita o la estrategia electoral
principalmente es aumentar
su piso político
cautivando a esa ese sector de la
población que puede puede ver pasos
importantes materia de Derechos Humanos
entonces creo que más allá de que sea
una voluntad en línea del gobierno creo
que fundamentalmente va a ser una
estrategia electoral para tratar de
cautivar a ese sector de la población
que cuando vea que el gobierno está
Estableciendo pasos concretos en materia
de Derechos Humanos pudiera tener un
refrescamiento de su imagen a nivel
electoral Williams lo tenemos de vuelta
otra vez hemos recuperado la conexión
con usted y Quiero preguntarle es tal
vez una pregunta común que hay en las
redes sociales diferentes analistas lo
han planteado En qué tanto necesita el
gobierno de maduro estos activos que
tiene Venezuela congelados en el
posterior para poderse financiar para
continuar en el poder para poder
garantizar llegar al 2024 con algo que
Mostrar para cautivar al electorado y
participar en esos comicios Busca estos
recursos para mantenerse en el poder o
porque verdaderamente la crisis en
Venezuela está en un punto de extrema
necesidad de esos recursos
Mira yo creo Santiago que
la gente está sufriendo mucho aquí en
Venezuela de eso no hay duda estos temas
recientes de los desastres naturales
puso en evidencia la vulnerabilidad del
mantenimiento de la infraestructura Vial
y agrícola del país ahora bien el
régimen han tenido dinero
no más con la venta de gasolina en
Divisas en las bombas de gasolina los
ingresos que recibe pdvsa diariamente y
sin ningún tipo de control es mucho
dinero
y yo creo que aquí hay un elemento
político de un marketing político de
victimización que quiere hacer el
régimen de echarle la culpa la tesis esa
conspirativa a alguien en este caso a
las sanciones Y por supuesto los dineros
congelados porque ese es el el discurso
que está utilizando Jorge Rodríguez yo
creo que realmente Ellos tienen recursos
para afrontar la emergencia humanitaria
y las necesidades del país ahora bien
Son recursos que en este momento como el
caso de los tres mil millones producto
este acuerdo social estén destinados a
cuestiones de ti o social no va a ser
suficiente esos tres mil millones de
dólares Yo creo que ahí es donde viene
el punto el modelo económico que tiene
el régimen es un modelo cerrado que no
permite inversiones
centralista que le quitó a las
provincias que le quitó los recursos de
los estados que los maneja directamente
el poder central y eso ha traído como
consecuencia un desastre institucional
en donde en la comunidad que que está
ahí directamente esperando la solución
de esos problemas con el centralismo ha
sido incapaz el régimen de lograr esas
soluciones inmediatas Entonces yo lo que
creo Es que están buscando una
argumentación para justificar 22 años de
fracaso económico y social qué es lo que
se caracterizado a este régimen Yo
quiero señalar algo que dijo el profesor
Víctor yo creo la reconciliación
Obviamente si tiene que haber una
Reconciliación en el país pero no puede
haber impunidad
importante ese punto y también poder
garantizar impunidad cuando volvemos a
lo mismo no hay una credibilidad en
torno a la independencia de poderes en
Venezuela no se puede creer en la
justicia no se puede creer en la
independencia electoral por lo menos así
lo han denunciado a nivel internacional
diferentes ongs y también otros
organismos internacionales que han
estado allí en Venezuela siguiendo estos
diferentes procesos Williams continuó
con usted y le preguntó por un actor
importante en toda esta negociación y es
Estados Unidos un país que como lo
decíamos ya le permitió a la petrolera
Chevron reactivar sus actividades en
Venezuela sabemos claramente y no es un
misterio ni es un ni está escondido ese
esa necesidad que tiene Washington de
acercarse a Venezuela precisamente por
los recursos del petróleo Pero qué tanto
está o estará dispuesto a ceder Estados
Unidos a hacerse la vista gorda con los
temas de derechos humanos de garantías
electorales y todo este Éxodo de los
venezolanos que han tenido que huir a
otros países para buscar las mejores
condiciones de vida creando una crisis
humanitaria a nivel regional simplemente
por el hecho de poder recibir petróleo
de Venezuela
Sí yo creo mira que la la contribución a
la crisis energética que ha hecho
Venezuela es de larga Data cuando la
Segunda Guerra Mundial los tanques del
ejército americano en Europa fueron
vamos a decirte auxiliamos por el
combustible que venía del petróleo
venezolano o sea Venezuela siempre ha
sido solidaria en la lucha por la paz en
el mundo y fue un activo importantísimo
en la Segunda Guerra Mundial para ayudar
a los ejércitos a los Estados Unidos en
Europa
yo creo pues que en este momento
Venezuela puede jugar un papel
importante en la en contribuir a
solucionar la crisis energética Pero
somos un país petrolero
y nosotros tenemos que ver la realidad
que tenemos como país petroleros con las
necesidades de la economía verde en
función del de la lucha contra el cambio
climático etcétera Pero como país
petrolero lo que sí tenemos que saber
sembrar el petróleo una vieja frase que
siempre se ha utilizado aquí en
Venezuela yo no creo que los Estados
Unidos vaya a sacrificar en sus valores
democráticos de libertad No porque para
los Estados Unidos el estado derecho el
cumplimiento de la ley es algo esencial
no Por más que haya pragmatismo en la
cuestión política y por los intereses
que puedan manejar los Estados Unidos
sin embargo sacrificar un tema de
derecho humano de un régimen que está
acusado en la Corte Penal Internacional
No es cualquier cosa Claro Víctor Hugo
qué piensa usted del papel de Estados
Unidos en toda esta negociación
bueno fundamentalmente el papel de
Estados Unidos comienza a tomar una gran
importancia debido a la situación en
Ucrania es decir el cambio de la
Administración baile de entender
estratégicamente de que necesita buscar
nuevos mercados evidentemente lo lleva a
iniciar un proceso de acercamiento con
el régimen de maduro no obstante creo
que es fundamental el el papel que que
que puede jugar la administración vaiden
con respecto a un debate que se viene
generando no solamente a lo interno de
los Estados Unidos sino también en
Europa el nivel de dependencia del punto
de vista energético que se tenga con
respecto al mercado que está dejando
Rusia en ese sentido colocaría en entre
la espada y la pared al gobierno de
maduro porque recordemos que el gobierno
de maduro tiene una alianza sobre todo
en el tema militar con Rusia entonces
creo que fundamentalmente
ahí en el caso de la Administración
biden en necesita hacer pasos mucho más
concretos a ver hasta qué punto puede
cubrir ese mercado pero es que hay un
gran problema hay un gran problema que
Venezuela no tiene esa capacidad de
refinación entonces ahí entraría el
papel de las transnacionales para
instalar esa infraestructura que le
permita tener un mercado seguro a corto
tiempo
de abastecimiento de combustible que
llega a los Estados Unidos entonces creo
que es fundamental también el escenario
interno de los Estados Unidos lo que es
la candidatura de Donald Trump lo que
tiene que ver lo que se va a definir con
respecto a un nuevo escenario electoral
donde evidentemente el electorado
norteamericano va a votar por el tema
económico y creo que va ese va a ser una
de las líneas centrales de la campaña y
va a ser un tema central el tema
Venezuela en una posible campaña
electoral donde Trump Busca Regresar al
poder y posiblemente baile Busca la
reelección Víctor Hugo Williams no puedo
dejar de preguntarles por un personaje
que está muchos lo han dicho está en las
sombras en esta negociación y es Alexa
está detenido en Estados Unidos su
esposa Camila fábrica hace parte de la
delegación del gobierno en esta mesa de
diálogo en México esta figura de Alexa
app que tan importante puede ser para
esta negociación y sobre todo su esposa
que está pues prácticamente
representandolo allí en esta mesa
es pieza clave en esta negociación
Víctor Hugo
Sin lugar a duda es una pieza clave
tomando en cuenta el papel que juegas a
app en todo lo que tiene que ver con los
negocios internos del régimen y
evidentemente lo que
significa desde el punto de vista de
posible intercambio de testimonios para
la justicia norteamericana pero que es
un punto de honor para el mismo gobierno
que que que que centra la figura de saad
evitando que sus declaraciones o sus
testimonios tengan repercusiones en el
amplio expediente que tienen la élite
del régimen para la justicia
norteamericana creo que va a ser un
punto fundamental un punto clave en el
proceso de negociación y que
evidentemente puede estar unido a a un
objetivo fundamental que tiene el
gobierno de más que todo que regreses a
add o recuperar sino recupere o evitar
que esa app de o suministre datos a la
justicia norteamericana donde esté
directamente vinculado con los negocios
de tráfico de droga tráfico de armas que
vienen adelantando desde hace ya un buen
tiempo los altos jerarcas del régimen y
William su opinión sobre esta pieza
clave Alexa app que vuelve a quedar otra
vez aquí expuesto en esta mesa de
diálogo y otra vez muy ligado al
gobierno venezolano Sí coincido con las
apreciaciones el profesor Víctor además
la señora
es alguien que tiene
deuda con la justicia Europea de manera
tal de que
me parece muy cínico que ahora ella
forme parte de esa comisión de diálogo
por parte del régimen que es como la
confesión de parte relevo de pruebas es
decir tanto el afán por depender Alexa
de la categoría diplomático de llevar a
su señora a formar parte de la mesa de
diálogo o de negociaciones en México que
algún temor tiene y uno de ellos es lo
que acaba de decir lo hizo Víctor
son de esas cosas Pues que que la gente
aquí en Venezuela no lo ve bien
indudablemente que ese es un pasivo
moral que tiene el régimen en el sentido
de qué cara le está dando al pueblo
venezolano que él mismo Está propiciando
maduro la impunidad para alguien cuyo
mejor
su gran logro diplomático es haber hecho
a mucha gente rico con el hambre del
pueblo venezolano con el comercio que
hizo con las bolsas y las cajas Clap así
pues de que indudablemente que ahí tiene
un interés supremo de maduro de tratar
de ocultar cosas de quitarle peso a la
información que pueda dar Alexa a la
fiscalía en los Estados Unidos Y de
alguna forma una pieza allí de
negociación para ver si le quitan
algunas sanciones o algunas cosas de
esas llegó ya la parte final de el
programa me quedan unos minutos para
hacer las conclusiones Williams comienzo
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
Qué espera entonces de esta mesa de
diálogo va a llegar esto a buen Puerto
van a concretar estos puntos que tienen
para discutir las partes usted como lo
ve Mira PC obviamente a mi juicio
crítico porque no le creo al régimen no
le creo y ya dije un ejemplo el primer
acuerdo parcial del año pasado fue sobre
el tema del ese equipo Ya estamos en la
Corte Internacional de Justicia y no
llamaron a nadie ni a la academia ni a
ninguno sectores de la vida nacional
para establecer la defensa de Venezuela
sin embargo soy optimista en el sentido
de seguir luchando porque el haber
llegado a este nivel
no es por una concesión gratuita de
régimen es porque se sintieron
presionados y obligados y por el afán de
limpiarse El rostro de mitigar sanciones
de Buscar recursos y de jugar siempre al
drible ahorita que estamos en el mundial
de fútbol tratar de vibrar a la
oposición con juegos adelantados y claro
una estrategia de opinión pública Yo
espero que efectivamente vayamos al
acuerdo político en el sentido de que
hayan elecciones libres se liberen los
presos políticos y eso es lo que es
esencial Víctor Hugo su conclusión para
el cierre Bueno si me permite
ya no hablar como docente ni académico
hablo como Ciudadano yo creo que
la posición y el gobierno
deben promover un acuerdo cercano a la
ciudadanía y no a sus intereses así como
los ciudadanos tenemos una opinión de
rechazo a todas las conductas y los
hechos realizados por el gobierno
también hay un descontento con la
dirigencia de la oposición porque se ha
demostrado que por debajo de Cuerda
tienen negocios con altos jerarcas del
gobierno Y creo que eso se le debe
hablar con la verdad la gente y debe
surgir debe surgir un acuerdo
estructural que garantice el tema de la
reconciliación el tema de derechos
humanos y también superar esa mentalidad
rentista que nos llevó a este desastre
económico y promover una economía
diversificada sobre todo
no podemos decir que Venezuela está
recuperada ni mucho menos está muy lejos
de ello pero en la leve mejoría porque
hay un grupo de importantes personas
empresarios que están dispuestos a
apostarle al tema del emprendimiento de
la innovación y que ya están hartos
hartos de la oposición y el gobierno y
quieren apostarle a distinta orientada a
lo que tiene que ver con el tema del
emprendimiento Pues a Víctor Hugo Juárez
y a Williams Dávila les agradezco por
este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 ya veremos En qué termina esta
mesa de diálogo entre el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y la oposición llevan
pocos días reunidos hay algunos pactos
preliminares pero quedan muchos temas
todavía por discutir y por ponerse de
acuerdo sobre todo de Cara a esas
elecciones del 2024 que van a ser
cruciales para la historia de Venezuela
les agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros a ustedes también en nombre de
todo el equipo técnico Les agradecemos
su sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Keila mestre y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Lina Guzmán Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]